[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this oh it's my Wednesday dance
welcome back to the break room it's our
daily show that keeps you updated on all
the nerdy news you need to know about
and coming up today Dave Batista is done
being silly put away the silly pills I
call cap on that yeah well we'll get
into it Wolverine takes the spotlight
what's new you know know what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying what's the name
James Cameron proves the ocean is better
than the sky and
much more uh I'm Jessica Clemens but who
cares about me because to my left we
have Brandon Baron oh hello happy to be
here happy to have you oh thank you to
my right we got Tommy back told I'm just
here so they don't find me okay oh okay
and it's a deep question Marshawn Lynch
at the Super Bowl hey
yes and the strongest man I've ever met
exactly whoa I'm raised thank you that's
not true
you guys we have an update on Jeremy
Renner yesterday he posted on Instagram
saying thank you all of your kind words
I'm too messed up now to type but I send
uh but I send love to you all our
thoughts and prayers are clearly with
him and go out to him and his family
with the speedy recovery and hopefully
it's a speedy speedy recovery yes all
the best a lot of folks Mark Ruffalo uh
Chris Evans all of them sending uh nice
words to him online hopefully probably a
lot of people reaching out direct to him
as well so many injuries days this week
I can't have it anymore no one else
please but everybody be safe um today uh
we don't have a Redemption but here are
some of the New Year's resolutions that
we missed that we didn't get to
yesterday and we're sorry about that but
we're going to give you guys some
leftover
new New Year's resolutions he wants to
go first uh TV Jones anytime you eat
spaghetti this year you have to put
sparklers in it like it's a VIP bottle
right burn your mouth yes you have to
eat the Sparkles no they are part of the
noodles now well you heard the man all
right JD
you know me feel same TV but then low
key I want you to learn how to carve
butter this year oh I want you to carve
my head in a bust of butter and then I
want you to eat every bit of that butter
until it goes down to your belly and you
Bellow Out Boy oh okay wow J Master you
know what I want you to read more this
year but just the last pages of books go
through a bookstore just read the last
page like 30 books
uh Charlie C uh start calling yourself
Charlie Charlie and see if anyone could
extreme
it's a good one Vega Bond of light I
want you to pay my electric bill
you get a bag amount of light yeah just
one would be good just one just bang off
one of those yeah uh Hannah basso I want
you to learn how to synchronize swim by
yourself oh I want to add a supplemental
one to Hannah Hannah basso I want you to
learn how to lasso so you can be lasso
and Hannah basso from El Paso maybe use
a little Brasso
um callable sassa oh that's right
talented members
okay uh let's let's get into uh the
topic the key topic of today's video or
what our thumbnail was all about in our
title uh so Deborah Joe Rupp this is
breaking news on yesterday's show uh was
announced as joining the cast along with
Catherine Hahn and a bunch of other
great people of Agatha Covenant of chaos
right uh Catherine Hans Not The Only One
Division cast member in there uh Emma
Caulfield Ford who played Dottie the
blonde uh neighbor uh Deborah Jerome of
course played the neighbor who came over
for dinner in the first episode right
now stop it yes
and and we don't know I mean they're
slowly leaking out these casting things
over the course the last few months so
we might get more Wanda Division cast
members joining we're going to get into
all the other people that have been
announced as a part of this show it's a
pretty deep cast already uh but this has
us asking around the office uh if this
series is just going to be a sequel or a
prequel to One Division or is it going
to be something different that's right
uh here's
oh it's almost like we were under a hex
hex
stop stop it okay stop it red Eric get
your dumb Friends out of the basement so
real quick just everything that we know
so far all the people that have been
cast
um Catherine Han love her Emma Caulfield
four hater
Deborah Joe Rupp all of them are back
from One Division we have to assume
they're probably playing their roles
from One Division and again a reminder
Kevin Hahn ended that series hexed
reverse hex it's still in Westfield uh
Emma Caulfield Ford and Deborah Joe
Webb's characters were hexed and
presumably were released from that hex
by the end of the show and they're
pissed probably
um Joe lost talented young actor will be
playing the male lead and is rumored to
be playing one of Wanda's sons all
growns up maybe a Tommy or a girl age
them up oh I have a little more on that
later okay put a pin in that uh Aubry
Plaza coming in hot off of the second
season of White Lotus Emily the criminal
on Netflix right now a nice little Indie
crying Thriller she's having a nice
little moment right here she's supposed
to be playing a villain we don't know
who that villain is but expected to be
the series villain a couple other actors
actresses Ali on Maria dizzia uh these
are maybe character actresses you
probably would recognize they've worked
to budge Patti LuPone Broadway goddess
come on Diva of Divas uh zameda SNL Alum
talented actress and
um one of the funniest weirdos in the
world Eric Andre
I have not joined the cast yet
yeah yeah yeah hey no uh his his phone's
working it is it is working finally
daddy paid the bill Merry Christmas
Tommy all right uh so kind of our
questions there that we want to try to
answer here today will these recurring
characters from One Division
be in more than one episode I know this
pivots off of your thought here Brandon
uh I don't think I think anyone from the
first season of Wanda vision is only in
the first episode and that'll get her
out of the hex and then she's off and
running and like this The Show Goes Way
Beyond One Division from there so I
think I think like Deborah Joe rep and
uh uh Emma Caulfield they're just in the
first episode you know what I agree I
agree with that because what if we see
her in the first episode the idea that I
imagine is because we leave one division
with uh Agatha just being her old like
silly self everybody else is normal
except for her yeah and they're like why
are you still acting like this we're not
under her head well when they all be
like we don't know you like me where'd
you come from are you being so weird and
how did you get this house well and now
that that presents a timeline question
because it's been two years since One
Division came out right that was 2020.
yeah uh no sorry 2021 right
um and we've already seen uh Wanda in
Multiverse Madness get into all kinds of
crazy chaos uh not a covenant of chaos
but crazy right and like one division
takes place a week after or very soon
after the events of end game it hasn't
been that long yeah I guess the Covenant
of chaos could take place while she's
reading the book before Multiverse and
Madness oh like uh before all that pops
up yeah interesting so this is taking
place before Moon night before uh Miss
Marvel before uh Thor 11 Thunder all
this stuff this is jumping back in time
a few years in the Marvel timeline
interesting well but that's where it
starts but you're saying we only see
these characters in the first episode
then she goes on the other side we could
have some time jumps yeah yeah during
the episode to maybe catch up to current
time potentially
um do we think multiverses get involved
in this show we're going to go to other
other multiverses I I don't believe so
my theory well I'm going to get into my
theory I believe no I think it's I think
this is going to be a bit of a uh a seek
kind of a An Origin story mixed with a
tie-in from Multiverse of Madness
whenever it's my turn to pop off just
let me know go okay so here's how it's
going to mirror one Division I mean
people are saying it's not one division
season two I believe this show will be
very similar to One Division in that the
first four episodes or so are gonna be
kind of explainers of how Agatha became
Agatha and and while that's happening
she's going to be like basically like a
Charles Dickens uh A Christmas Carol if
you will there's going to be a character
leading her through this rediscovery of
who she is healing her mind getting her
out of Westview Westview Westfield
Westfield Westfield is the mall
Westfield yeah Westfield is where I go
to get my hats that are too small which
is why big hats may be coming to a
channel near you soon that's right now
anyway so there is a mysterious
character who is going to be trying to
get Agatha to get her mojo back by
taking her through the 1600s 1700s each
episode will be a hundred years later uh
culminating in 2000s uh in episode four
where uh where where we will she will
finally snap on out of it who is this
character it's Billy from earth838 no
Billy from Earth 838 couldn't help but
feel a little bit sorry for his mother's
Universal doppelganger multiversal
doppelganger that got him interested in
the dark arts they got him interested in
a little bit of magic he discovered his
Wicked Powers he aged himself up a
little bit he's gonna be played by Joe
Locke and now he's messing with it he's
creating a coven of chaos to try and get
his mommy from the other Multiverse bag
wow he feels a connection to wander from
Multiverse of Madness so Billy as Wiccan
is gonna bring back the Scarlet Witch
now who will be opposing them
who will be opposing Wiccan someone who
first tried to help him Aubry Plaza's
character I believe will be a powerful
witch from Earth 838 perhaps even an
Agatha Harkness of himself from 838
causing an Agatha squared Showdown
ladies and gentlemen I rest my case oh
wow you're out of order oh my gosh this
whole Court's out of order uh
interesting you know in the comics
Wiccan not normally a bad character he's
a member he's a member of the Young
Avengers he's a bad boy yeah
why do good girls like bad boys bad boy
song about it again
um yeah a frequent member of the Young
Avengers uh you know we've Marvel's been
building this deep bench of potential
Young Avengers with no signs of them
ever actually forming the Young Avengers
they're just out there they're all too
old
they're gonna be the old Avengers by the
time it happens not just Avengers it's
like fat Thor you don't have to call him
fat Thor he's just Thor he's on thick
Thor now ooh thick Thor thicker I'm
gonna call myself fixed on me
uh now do what again we know I I think I
don't know that it has been confirmed
that Joe Locke is playing no that's just
a rumor billy slash Wiccan we could
check in with uh uh one of the little
actors the little actors who currently
play Billy and Tommy yeah friend of the
channel who sometimes yeah responds to
everybody boss on Twitter he's waiting
for a call I mean the habit of the
Cassie learning
actresses however like we said now Billy
has ties to Mephisto we know we're
getting Mephisto perhaps a Faustian
bargain is struck to make him old enough
to travel because one thing about 838
that was mysterious if you think about
it from Multiverse Advantage there was
not a lot of children shown I mean I
think billion times were the only
children we even saw out of the streets
none of the background actors were
children now that could have been a
logistical thing during a pandemic where
it's just easier to have adult actors
but it appeared to be this utopian
society where kids are not around like
they're Eric Eric pointed that out in
some breakdowns
pointed it out as well I'm just kidding
I don't need that kind of cloud around
here that's not what I'm about but maybe
Billy needs to change his appearance in
order to leave 838 and go to 616. who
could help him the Devil Himself oh and
now we we've got got this rumor that
Sasha Baron Cohen has been cast as
Mephisto yeah when is he scheduled to
show up in Iron Heart Right which should
be coming out before yeah Covenant of
chaos if nothing gets delayed or moved
um yeah so he will be in the MCU by the
time clock in the background of
ironheart that says 8 38 is the time
that'll be all the clues I need the
clues are everywhere connect the dots
um do we think Wanda or white Vision
will show up in this series
I would love to see a Wanda by the end
of it uh and what what timeline Wanda
would this be well I mean they've
they've they have said that like Wanda's
not we don't know if Wanda is dead right
and for all intents and purposes you
shouldn't kill off 616 Wanda off screen
off screen I said we saw the mountain
collapse of the little red puff of
energy but like she shouldn't be dead
nobody no death right that's right so
like that's a Bob Marley song right
nobody nobody no death that's true
I like the idea that like because it was
implied that Wanda kind of took Powers
away from Agatha uh and takes over the
dark called right then purple fingers
got them purple fingers purple black
fingers going so Wanda or Agatha might
be like if I'm gonna get back up I need
to get my OG powers back and she might
be the Catalyst to bring back Wanda
solely for the purpose do you think
she's sifting through the rubble of
wondering Mountain there that's what I'm
hoping yeah
oh my God because again all all of the
dark holds are destroyed across all
universes right and the uh the book of
Ashanti which only exists there's only
one that one's gone too so that's all
gone and we no wonder Gourmet was full
of the original uh inscribings of the
Dark Hall there was a copy of Wonder
gold mountain and it's not completely
destroyed it's kind of how is this
impacted by the Necronomicon that we all
just saw in the evil evil dead Rise
trailer she also takes a cheese grater
to the left yeah yeah uh uh Agatha grabs
a chunk of Dotty's hair and rips the
back of her stuff and you guys have you
guys seen that trailer yet it might be
something might be coming up on the new
rockstars trip I think it's so funny
that something's coming up in my throat
and watching that trailer zombie screams
in the office it seems like uh Sam rayme
produces is producing Evil Dead rise and
it's like he's like I wanted to do this
so bad news that PG-13 in
yeah no Carrie Dabbs asked a great
question Carrie dabs no I assume those
are the kind of dabs you're talking
about Carrie now you said what if the
side characters from one division are
actually witches as well
like you think you're the only guys on
the inside I was thinking if they were
descendants of the because we see her
when she has to go back in her memory or
whatever and she's being
um about to be set on fire amongst the
other witches if they are descendants of
the other which is because those other
witches are not alive anymore and if
they all do wander to West View at one
point like would that also give Agatha
her powers back just being a part of her
original coven oh I like the descendants
of her Covenant kind of awaken her yeah
I mean those two actresses they were the
characters that broke out of the hex the
most they were like the glitches in The
Matrix stop it and then Dottie and the
Magic episode was very peculiar and
strange it's just she had the broken
glass yeah it would almost make sense if
they were powerful enough to almost
break out because they had oh they're
like yeah right Ned who's got sleeping
magic powers maybe they have like latent
powers and I love the idea that they're
descending of those witches yeah and
like that's well where those Powers come
from real quick let's do a lightning
round what our best prediction is for
like what the overall plot of Covenant
of chaos is gonna be a reminder this is
of the upcoming Marvel shows besides
Echo that has been kind of shot but is
kind of delayed we don't know where
that's going to land this will be uh the
final one this year uh probably at the
end of this year maybe beginning of next
year after after ironheart after secret
Invasion after Loki season two maybe
after Echo we don't know when that's
coming but then this one okay what's our
what's our big picture prediction for
what the plot's all about so yeah going
off of uh Agatha breaks out first
episode leaves Westview behind bye guys
uh I see it as like a Kung Fu The Legend
Continues s story where uh Agatha's
wandering Earth finding other witches
because she knows where they are from
her previous days and either like
usually then to get her powers back or
stealing their powers is this reawakened
uh yeah she's no longer yeah no
flashbacks no nothing she's out of the
hex she's traveling the Earth uh and
maybe I'll be Plaza plays like the
ultimate witch that she needs to get to
in order to get powerful enough to bring
back Wanda oh and get her all over
Highlander style yeah yeah love it
Jessica what's your prediction I think
that a mine's a much more tamed version
it is I think it is going to be uh the
coven coming together and trying to
release Agatha out of uh whatever grip
she's in but I think ultimately this is
going to be an introduction of not
Agatha I think it's going to be uh and I
think we're gonna get into the midnight
Suns through this
it's because this coven is going to try
to get her out and the only way to do
that is by going in and going in is
going to go see like nightmare or maybe
even going to see uh The Ghost Writer
but I think it's going to be going to
hell I don't think it's going to be a
SEMA Fisto I don't think it's gonna be
that I think we're gonna try bringing in
a new person since mephist is going to
show up in ironheart and I'd rather have
his origin be like in Iron Heart than
this uh go forward and then back would
be too much so I think they're gonna
have to go into hell to get her to come
back out I want to see Agatha under the
hex working in a bakery we hear a
motorcycle outside the shop
he's like my girlfriend's trapped in
here and you're bringing back I'm
bringing it back in this case I would
scream if she was dating him bring me a
Danish
that's a pretty good Nick Cage Tommy
you've already kind of stated your
Charles Dickens uh Christmas Carol kind
of uh mine goes in the format of uh of
of of like a soccer last five of English
football WLW WLW uh Wiccan leaves World
loving Wanda
yes Dickens going for his mommy from
another denami uh
uh Dimension uh but yeah I think it's
going to be Wicked trying to save uh the
woman who tried to kill his real mother
in a38 because he feels that woman seems
to have suppressed her magic right okay
he likes that Wanda from 616 let her
freak Clegg fly in the Multiverse of
Madness so he's going to uh he is going
to meet Mephisto sorry haters and uh
that's gonna lead to him changing and
looking like Joe Locke and then he's
gonna go unlock I guess huh all while
being pursued by 838's Agatha played by
Aubry Plaza oh I like these ideas here's
my pitch and I think one thing I liked
about Jessica's the most is her pitch
actually incorporates the idea of a
coven the most there's a reason like
remember this was originally called
House of Harkness they pivoted it to
Covenant he's gonna get Tim Gunn and
they were gonna build up make it work
they were going to make it work look at
Magic
um but I think there's a reason it's
called Covenant of chaos right there is
going to be it's gonna be a squad of
which is somehow involved but I think
I'm gonna emphasize my pitch the chaos
part of that I think the show's gonna be
nuts yeah uh I think it's gonna
incorporate elements you've all talked
about I think there's gonna be
flashbacks hundreds of years in the past
I think there they'll be multi uh
multiversal traveling yeah let's go to
hell why not um and other parts of New
Jersey
they don't make pizza with garbage on it
but New Jersey
okay happy New Year what's the New
Jersey New Year it's got to be Halloween
right okay uh but I think like expect
unexpected especially you don't hire
Eric Andre unless you want chaos
anybody's watched any of his Adult Swim
work he's gonna show up naked yeah yeah
the first the first butt cheek we see in
the MCU maybe oh
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry it might be the
first gorilla [ __ ] if we're lucky uh
if you've seen his earlier
hey I agree with you I want the chaos I
just had this thought do we think they
changed the name House of Harkness
because that was too much of a giveaway
that this is going to revolve around
Harkness witches family these are all
going to be family members it's going to
be sisters
aunts uh you know whoever and they were
like this is too obvious everyone will
figure this out so Covenant of chaos can
imply that they're not all going to end
up well and like the the facts we know
in the MCU there's a lot of comics lower
around Agatha of course but in the MCU
well we know she's hundreds of years old
right she was getting attacked by all
these witches in Salem way back in the
day and she kind of reversed it on them
and her own mother her own mother and
all these other witches and then
survived to present day where she's
dealing where she went after Wanda right
we don't know what she did in those
hundreds of years she could have been
having kids she could have had other
cousins wandering around trying out
puppets out of wood wishing them to life
we don't know he's gonna lost a ton to
Bernie Madoff we don't know yeah maybe
she got in early on nft maybe she got
out late maybe she's got born
okay but we are so excited and again we
can only anticipate that once every two
weeks we will get a new uh announcement
keep releasing slowly leaking out I feel
like we know four cast members for
ironheart we know 200 cast members for
Kevin of chaos already uh same with what
is it uh the acolyte we have like yeah
everyone's throwing out people too yeah
I heard Pee-Wee Herman's gonna be oh no
Paul rubins characters
hey folks do you want to save more and
spend less than 20 years yes of course
you do stop paying insane amounts of
money every month for your phone bill
right now when you switch to Mid mobile
you'll get their unlimited plan for 50
off net mobile lets you order from home
and save a ton with phone plan starting
at just 15 a month but you have to hurry
because this deal we're offering today
ends January 15th so again 11 days I
know get get your act together it's
beginning of the year folks man mobile
is kicking off the year with their best
offer ever before January 15th by any
three month plan and get three months
free any any any plan even their
Unlimited Plan Tommy by going online
only and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mint mobile passes
significant savings onto you and all
their plans they're great they come with
unlimited talking text high speed data
and it's all delivered on the nation's
largest 5G Network you can use your own
phone uh and switch to any mobile plan
in minutes with their esim uh switch to
Mid mobile now and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month if you buy any three month Mobile
plan and you get three more months free
by going to mintmobile.com break room
that's mintmobile.com breakroom cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
memmobile.com
again you gotta hurry up because this
offer is over January 15th shout out to
Ryan Reynolds yeah co-owner of mint
mobile that guy has a soccer team as a
soccer team in Wales has a mobile uh
phone company has a and a gym Aviation
gym and then Blake Lively are expecting
their fourth challenge
he's got my family in the basement and
if I don't give him two million dollars
I'll never see them again now I'm still
thinking of a mint mobile man myself you
may notice these green threads I'm a
minty man now I'd have to wear green
contractually a rhino come for me oh
okay well we don't not the way I want
oh boy hey yo okay uh you you thought
you're gonna get through this episode
without some headlines what no you
thought wrong let's do some headlines
hey um we got this is late breaking this
just happened the last few hours we got
some new images for some of our most
anticipated upcoming movies John roll
some of those beautiful images look
that's it man uh cast members quantumnia
that's a very tan family of things oh
that's from oh no this debunks my theory
that his mom is a ghost in that seat she
could still be a ghost maybe they're
only talking to the dad okay she's like
listen to me so much oh the last images
like your mother's full of maggots
I will never see that film sorry Sam
Raimi sorry to the artist that created
it I will not see your film because I
like to sleep at night tight with a
pillow wrapped around my arms uh I think
we have a third do we have a third image
oh yeah oh little Guardians uh volume 3
if you get close to your screens right
now nebula's arm is very different
looking yeah yeah she's very strange
looks like looks just like she made
Bucky's fake arm oh more Bucky's real
arm no it's not real James Gunn said he
came down she came down yeah I will say
and maybe we'll have content on the
channel about this it does look slimmer
than Bucky's arm it's not quite as uh
man muscled she took that I think she's
sleeping off I think she's just really
good at making mechanical arms now
because she's had to repair her own arm
and Val in volume one and two twice so I
think she's just making these arms yeah
maybe she wants other she wants others
like features right it's just cute as a
button
confirm pictures also uh a good pivot
that last photo a very clothed Drax yeah
I mean he long sleeves
not just just head makeup uh Dave
Batista who's out doing promo uh
promotional work for Glass Onion great
movie uh he told GQ in a recent
interview that he is ready to move on
from Drax well good news
he gets to
um he said I'm so grateful for Drax I
love him I just don't know if I want
Drax to be my legacy it's a silly
performance and I want to do more
dramatic stuff now he goes on to say
like um you know obviously the putting
on the makeup was very taxing you know
people for film makeup has to be so good
especially this is them this isn't like
uh you know hey you want to do Halloween
or even you're doing cosplay or
something like that you know it had for
close-ups for all this kind of stuff it
has to be so incredibly good so people
like Dave Bautista's Drax Karen Gillum
as a nebula right like they have to sit
in those chairs I mean for hours every
day look how hard they do the like the
porn parody makeup is so on point yeah
okay it ain't porno blush anymore guys
realistic drugs now here's what I think
I guess I gotta interject on this I
think Saldana gave an interviewer she's
like I'm done yes uh uh Batista's doing
an interview like I'm done Chris what's
his name is
song praying up eerily silent uh I think
they're throwing us off the scent guys I
think the Guardians they're trying to
make it seem like I think they're all
like we're done we couldn't okay our
fourth movie I couldn't need another
slice if you paid me sneak a sniper I
think I think uh this is clear evidence
that Dave Bautista's gonna die I think
him being like I'm so glad to be out of
this franchise and it's like oh out of
it like you're you're leaving the MCU
completely yeah
I think that's a good call I also think
you know it's like when you get out of a
long-term relationship that made it
maybe was a little rough at the end
you're like I'm gonna be single for a
while right you know what I mean you're
not running he's been sitting in makeup
also he gets to do something like Glass
Onion that's a little bit different role
Force rated it's great it's a great
movie it's a different thing he's not in
front of a green screen all movie and
he's not covered in makeup maybe he's
just a little burned out I bet swing
back to him in two years he won't mind
that that role is his signature because
guess what a lot of actors never get
like a signature performance and this
this third movie has it's been a roller
coaster right because James gone was uh
away from Marvel for a little while and
drag or tracks Batista was a very big
proponent of like I don't want to do
this movie without James Gunn and like I
think it's been stressful and he's happy
to be done and if you want to stretch
your acting chops come do an improv show
with us hey let's do some sketch Davey
let's get in you know what the best
actors can do sketch comedy okay Dave
come to a sketch show with us we'll
we'll we won't paint you up like a
little doll what kind of uh accent work
and Impressions you think Dave Batista
can do oh I mean I I bet he can do a
really really really good Morgan Freeman
okay I was gonna say a Louisiana one
would be fun to watch
Brandon does a good trim boat captain
[Music]
that's true uh well and again we need a
new term on the phrase of course on
break room we talk about thirsty
thespians when actors are clearly
advocating for themselves to be given
more marble roles there it is
what's the opposite what's so Superstar
it's already ruined it's so super that's
the opposite of a Thursday Super Soaker
Stars uh while begging the academy to
not give Ryan Reynolds a best song
nomination for spirited uh Hugh Jackman
referred to the upcoming Deadpool 3 as
Wolverine and Deadpool I think do we
have a clip
I mean I have to spend a year with him
shooting Wolverine and Deadpool and it
trust me it would be impossible it'd be
a problem
I can't break out of this prison that I
mean White Walls everywhere uh and then
Ryan Reynolds uh threw up a tweet in
response also Wolverine and Deadpool Bob
uh note note that Wolverine gets first
yeah right uh do you think it'll be
called Deadpool and Wolverine no
well I you know him referring to this
you know they movies have different
names on the script than they do when
the final people don't even know what
it's going to be he's just an actor he
shows up he reads what's on the page I'm
not surprised if like the script they've
been shooting with says Wolverine and
Deadpool he also might not have the full
script of the movie I don't know how
much Wolverine there is in this movie
have they started shooting uh I think so
they've been together what's that John
I know that Hugh Jackman had to wrap up
the music man I think he's finished with
the now but I know that was like
wrapping up uh his role in there how
many trombones were involved uh I
believe 75 no 76. wow one year they'll
add one more knock the world off of
taxes no I real quick I want to do a
quick lightning I'm gonna add a quick
lightning round okay how on a scale of
one to ten uh Deadpool quickly remarks
how much are they gonna desecrate James
mangold's The Wolverine uh like Logan I
mean are they gonna well he also
directed the world but Logan is the one
I'm talking about thank you but are they
going to show Deadpool like pulling him
off the tree trunk like that he's
impaled that how much are they gonna
desecrate that movie or is it just gonna
be he grabs him out of a timeline
somewhere well now that this is Disney
right right how much can they well you
know they're they're gonna go r on this
yeah well also I mean again they've been
doing all this promotional work uh you
know Hugh Jackman showing up in this
what are the odds he's in less than a
third of this movie I think he'll be in
a lot of them okay I said this and then
we saw the art that had his scratch over
it oh that's right you got a surprise
run-in from producer John the facts here
are the facts okay they've said uh it's
gonna be sort of a two-hander so he'll
be in a lot of the movie has not started
shooting they're in prep right now uh
and what was what were you just saying
me yeah oh how much are they gonna
desecrate uh oh they said since they're
using TBA stuff and all the stuff it
takes like this before Logan and Logan
will still be in the Canon of I mean
maybe they'll make fun of it like they
didn't it's like a variant right but
it's supposed to be one place before and
and Logan takes place in the future
anyways right so you can jump back okay
guys hey I just asked the questions okay
thank you producer John
no John come back and yell at him
democracy dies in darkness everyone fair
and balanced uh but but also uh fun all
their little weird quippy back and forth
uh
Hugh Jackman finds a way to slip in one
little Deadpool Factor factoid into
every uh interview he does just so we
will talk about it thank you little Jack
Man by the way all my fellow Jack offs
were meeting at the Hollywood Bowl
that's what the Jackman fans called Jack
offs unite and the Holiday Bowl of
course not the performance venue
Highlander the toilet uh that's the
toilet at the burgundy room uh that has
been pissed in by more Academy Award
winners than any other toilet in this
great City so meet me at the bowl Jack
offs it's gonna be a great time you're
not going to want to not come to this oh
print that t-shirt
okay Avatar way of the water uh hey it's
still the number one movie in America I
think yeah around the world I drowned
the New Year's weekend box office
estimates uh uh way of water uh rising
to over 1.5 billion dollars globally
it's now surpassed top gun Maverick as
the highest grossing film of 2022. I
believe that's that's worldwide yeah
still isn't beaten Maverick domestic I
don't think but Maverick was in theaters
for a long time I don't cut its Cube and
then came back again yeah now that
January the first has become calendar
fact I don't count its cue moving
forward so if it made any of those
dollars on the first section I drop its
Cube I adjust its Cube disrespect to the
cube uh variety is reporting that James
Gunn and Peter saffron's three-year I've
heard five year I thought well they were
saying like 10 for a while but that's
just like a magic number they've got all
kinds of chapters of plans but their
three-year DCU plan won't include Henry
Cavill Superman or Wonder Woman at all
well we kind of knew that sources
describe it as a broad but not blanket
reset interesting Aquaman Shazam Blue
Beetle and guns peacemakers series for
HBO Max all could have a place in the
table that's interesting could so no
guarantees that we know of yet and
that's going forward like we know we're
getting an Aquaman movie A shazam movie
and a Blue Beetle movie this year uh
Peacemaker season two has yet to be
announced we don't think they've gone
into production yet so it's probably not
coming this year maybe it could yeah
it's been announced but no production as
far as we know
um interesting what do you guys think
about that news I don't make sense I
find it exciting I I think you know I
think you know the aqua man the Mamoa to
from Aquaman to Lobo seems fun and
provocative but really if they could
keep him as Aquaman does it make sense
to reset him as another character there
are plenty of other good actors that are
like muscle bound you know hunky guys to
play Lobo so I yeah I don't know I don't
know that I need I like the idea that
it's not a uh a full reset it's just a
not a blanket reset as they said
blankets it's a difficult word here at
our office so it's it's a tough we say
it's just it's a light reset it's a soft
launch and I like that yeah yeah I still
think that this Flash movie has some
explanation of all the other multiverses
in the DC Universe and they just need to
get that out and then they're like once
you guys see this movie everything will
be fine and DC will move forward with
like it'll I think I think Ghan and
saffron want to establish some sort of
interconnected thing but I think they're
still gonna have like over half of their
movies be their own thing yeah and it is
a neat dog and we know they don't want
to chase Marvel's ambulance no and Joker
too yeah happening uh more Matt Reeves
Batman movies happening and the TV shows
in that Universe also the the penguin
show which is I guess they I keep
forgetting the exact details of this and
this is bad badge live stream but like
they're folding in the Gotham Police
Department Show into the penguin show
right isn't that what it is they're just
making yeah they're making one shot yeah
I think I think there was potential
there was going to be the Gavin Petey
show
there's no there's no shows mentioned
but I think the only one that's like
actively moving forward is the Penguin
show all I know is they better bring
back the captain of the Gotham Police
Department what does he sound like get
this freak out of here
it sounds like three little captains in
a trench coat doesn't it every time I do
it it gets a little bit higher but he
does sound like that watch our flag
means that he plays a completely
different character what's his name I
[ __ ] voice real quick we wanted to
shout out a couple of uh folks super
chatting thank you to everybody in the
chat and everybody's standing in super
chats we appreciate you Rupert Jamison
does anyone at NR play Marvel snap oh
baby you better believe it much of my
wife should Grant I play a lot of Marvel
snap just passed over the Thousand level
for the collection whatever they call
that collection oh just pass a thousand
nice word several other behind the
scenes staff and new rock stars are also
very addicted to Marvel snap
um Quentin clone Force 99 back in Action
baby that's right uh bad batch that's
right the bad batch your boy's been bad
batch binging and I'm ready to be pork
that I think the show is great
Tommy Tommy did get some exclusive yeah
oh baby you think you guys got your two
episodes
that's Child's Play wait for all my
thoughts on the bad batch and some
videos upcoming on this channel if I
don't get fired after this episode now
do we want to read any more of these
full super chats we'll come back to them
thank you to everybody sending it guess
what
it's 20 23 and it's time for mandatory
fun
oh my God
yeah you couldn't tell from my fantastic
see uh
the jet just melted with anybody wearing
headphones
take your headphones out you children
pony horses in the chat room phone
horses freaking cheese graters in the
chat uh
mommies and maggots in the chat oh my
God the poor mods all right now it's
time for mandatory fun uh this is the
first mandatory fun of
2023. so play the graphic again for me
[Applause]
so play The Thirsty thespians graphic
over there
cause I'm low wrong and I'm strong so
play the graphic again John
yeah now ladies yeah ladies yeah you
want to play my mandatory fun games
even white boys got the shout play the
graphic again oh wow he is a white boy
and he didn't show oh Tommy confirmed
white boy some people think I'm royalty
now man peppermint toy fun now today's
mandatory fun is all about the topic of
the year so far everyone in 2023 can't
stop talking about nepotism babies
Napo babies that make the dreams come
true
Napo babies mom's a bit more famous than
you oh when you want to wear a suit but
all you are is kinda cute yes close your
eyes and ask your dad he'll make a
costume at shoes nepo nepo nipple never
up baby baby
[Applause]
no I was born in 2002 so I don't get
that reference yes that's a reference
wrong with it like you didn't know I
looked it up as a reference to the
Muppet Babies a popular French cartoon
from 1981. now and so now I'm currently
also on Disney Disney kiddos or whatever
it's called Disney kids Disney kiddos
Disney plus Disney no there's like the
kids Channel Disney oh you know it's the
one that's made for kids it's got like
vampirina Disney XD I don't know
I think it's called Disney
today we're talking about MCU in Canon
nepo babies now obviously we can expect
some new nepo babies coming out when
Fantastic Four hits you know I'm talking
Nathaniel Richards you know but until
then I'm gonna list some kids off I'm
gonna list some nepo famous kids off
really really hit the ball
my stroked off when I stroked out when I
was writing that stroked out
home run now
I'm gonna name some famous MCU okay
adult fully formed adults who are
children of famous people and you guys
are going to tell me are they nepo
babies
or did they earn it man these are not
the actors these are the characters
they're actors would be all of them okay
you know you can link every famous
person to a famous parent or Uncle
except for me no contacts to this
industry in fact when I moved to
Hollywood Wired Magazine said
okay
first up Tony Stark I mean big time no
do you know you haven't even called him
an apple baby carrots
billions of dollars we don't know how
much the Stark industry is worth He
inherits a fully formed company is put
at the head of it yeah even though
Obadiah stains probably a better uh CEO
that he is right uh uh using the family
name posting on that got all sorts of
Industries given to him not just weapons
well but don't you think there's a
difference pre-ironment one Tony Stark
definitely nepo baby sure post Iron Man
one seems like he earned it yeah you
think I was gonna say all of them still
earn it it's the resources that make
them go ahead however at the end of the
day the only resources he had was a cave
little box of scraps
but it's still it's like there's another
student that could have had the same
resources I think I think definitely my
I mean as much as I do think he he had
he's obviously still a genius but the
the things that would have helped him uh
get to be the Tony Stark that he is we
were all establishing he's also his dad
worked at the company
he wasn't joining you no that's the
definition that's the definition
well and and to be fair and the way
we're talking about it nepo baby it
doesn't have to be a terrible thing I
was just acknowledging you had the
access your advantages it doesn't it
doesn't make Kate Hudson any less of a
treasure in Glass Onion to know that she
is a Bonafide nephro baby and by the way
I'm a nepo baby my dad started the first
Spearmint Rhino get out of here yeah
okay so wait does that mean you're a
stripper nepo baby that's right I'm a
net pole baby
nipple baby I do have perfect nipples oh
okay don't Google it uh
multiple times uh we blurted out right I
was told we blurted out
you go to my only fans now hope van
dying oh I'm gonna say no because she's
like she goes by her mom's name she can
go by but she works what about that suit
where'd she get that she works for her
dad
he's not at the company she works for
Darren cross she hated her dad remember
how did she get that job
[Applause]
but isn't it the exact same thing as
Tony Stark yeah and are we going by just
hope then the woman hope van dime are we
going by the WASP because her entire
Persona now is the wasp and she got the
freaking Passover for a white man for
the position right first Ant-Man got the
suit and then she got to be look doesn't
matter in the sequel that's true shut
the camera off
[Laughter]
I didn't get a lot of sleep last night I
only got 14 hours next Cassie Scott okay
well and and we don't know quite yet
we're gonna find out a lot more in
quantumania we're gonna get a lot more
screen time with her right but it seems
like no baby yeah quadruple nepo baby
Grandpa Grandma Mom yeah kind of well I
guess those are all in-laws I'm sorry
well they're not married either but kind
of like a nepo baby in the way that like
Woody Harrelson is an apple baby because
his dad was a murderer it's like her
Scott Lang what what it's Cassie Lang
not Cassie Scott first of all like
Cassie Lang Cassie Lang her father's
like a known criminal that was like he's
like
no wait Woody Harrelson's dad yes
famously yeah he's in prison he died in
prison for murder I think I don't know
I'm famous wherever he is how do I know
this God Woody if you're watching the
show come on in come on I will say
Cassie had to go through her formative
years without dad around he was in stuck
in there and I take it back I was
thinking like oh Janet and Hank but like
those aren't really related to her
um they've probably embraced her
recently causing grandpa in the trailer
yeah good point I don't know I'm just
saying I don't know how hardcore we want
to out these people because previous
iterations of Cassie we've never seen
her do anything heroic until this movie
true I like to imagine that scotling's
parents are still alive but he doesn't
go hang out with them yeah he's like my
father-in-law is way cool yeah I'm gonna
say yes but it sucks because it's not
direct I don't think it's directly from
Sky I think it's directly from the pin
yeah kind of adopted grandparents that
makes her because she again I'm sorry to
keep being that person but uh she was
able to get her dad like remember when
in the first movie where uh what's his
name was coming to arrest him and they
had the aunt portraying him the entire
time she was able to do all those things
with Hank pym's technology distract so
her Dad wouldn't go back to prison
whereas another kid that doesn't have
those Pim things their dad would just go
back to prison I just gotta step dad as
a cop that's right but we kind of ah
okay all right finally all right not
finally uh we will get to that we're
gonna cut a few of these uh Gamora
nebula Daughters of Thanos in a bad way
but I'm the worst way possible I would
say
could they not be dead if they were not
Daughters of Thanos I mean the sheer
fact that they breathe space air but he
killed the family and took only Gamora
yeah I don't know if you if you call
your daughter if you're a stolen child
can you still be a nepo he goes
yes because now in the Galaxy no one's
gonna mess with you because you're the
daughter my parents killed my parents to
raise me and I thanked him every day
goes to prison in the first film they're
all ready to kill her all the other
prisoners are ready to kill her because
she is the donor so it's a disadvantage
the distance
it hasn't worked out well for me and
certainly as portraying the MCU we don't
know what happened before she before
Guardians won but like everything we've
seen Gamora accomplished has been
despite her father not because of her
father was helping out with a few of
those kids Bing Crosby was no Peach but
his kids all sure appreciated that
Crosby last name when they were going
into the old Paramount Studios to get
seven picture deals to make westerns
okay sometimes a little rod from Bing
was worth the bottom Bing ching ching
from the Paramount Pockets finally Peter
Quill oh that's a good one beautiful he
got the he's a Star-Lord because of his
dad but he didn't know right he assumed
it on his own yeah now I think you can
make an argument
instead of benefiting from uh ego being
his father he kind of more benefited
from that's right wow so he's a double
nepo baby yeah genetically and both the
uh nature and nurture nematism there the
thing is it's still
it's just so hard to chew because all of
the Marvel characters are nepo babies
except for like the newer ones I would
say like Miss Marvel and iron heart I
mean black widow her her mom just got
Peter Parker Peter Parker and then like
yeah the newest thing America Chavez and
with a lot of those characters the young
surprisingly it's the young people yeah
I mean okay Bishops
oh that's a definition literal nepo baby
now
obviously we've there's plenty in the
MCU we see the nepotism exists on screen
in a fictional form and off screen in
the form of Wyatt Russell Robert Downey
Jr and so many more that we could name
Gwyneth Paltrow all the kids in Thor
love and Dutch that's right uh but the
biggest nepo baby of all time is
obviously Rey Palpatine Skywalker right
Stolen Valor from two different names uh
talk about using two names that you did
it I think you dropped the palpits and
the least nippo baby my boy kylo Ren
changed his name to get away from being
Ben solo didn't want to be Ben solo
didn't want to meet Ben Skywalker I
still didn't you don't think he still
benefited from nepotism
maybe maybe his uncle knew a guy maybe
his uncle was the guy maybe he knew what
Chewbacca we all we all benefit in one
way or another I got an uncle with too
much hair that didn't make me special I
got this job through Eric
but you're not related to Eric no but
he's my friend yeah but that's not
nepotism I think that's a different
thing I think nepotism has to be
familiar does it have to be
remember out of high school
was like no that'd be nepotism I can't
do that good for him that's not related
Derek but I do have his DNA all over me
um see you at the bowl see you at the
bowler
I want to go and this is the second day
in a row on the show that we've only
done twice this week but I said I want
to go ah well that's a good time maybe I
should take Thursday off would that be
good for everyone I don't want to stay
it's gonna be a tough year oh thank you
thank you to everybody that said in a
Super Chat uh David yeshimoto uh Aaliyah
fui Moana that's a beautiful name
Aaliyah Elia I'm not sure I pronounced
it right DJ cold cuts Quentin Rupert
Jamison we showed you out Bucky Barnes
Gary dabs we read that earlier uh Trey
Wharton uh Chuck Stillwell that's a
strong name yeah it's a real name our
buddy Chris Christian unpronounceable
from the Frozen North coming in oh Fan
Expo Christian I'll tell you what I
don't know if we're gonna get the whole
new rockstars gang at Fan Expo but I I
am planning on attending Fan Expo this
year uh it's up in Toronto Toronto it's
a great time they get great guests it is
well you just get your ones
if Fan Expo Christian one thing you can
do for us that would be helpful
tell Fan Expo you want us to come Yeah
the more that they know that people want
the rock stars coming over they want the
breakers they want the break room uh the
better the chance of us uh getting
actually being able to get there but we
would love to go we'd love to Toronto's
a lovely if not just meet me at a Tim
Hortons Christian well cheers a nice
coffee JB Riley also said answer which I
think so much
uh oh and the salamander the salamander
that's a strong name lots of strong
names that come to El Paso Comics El
Paso I'll be at Emerald City with Hannah
basa doing her lasso with Will Sasso we
might uh I got a lot of gas Jamie Riley
we are working or sorry there was a
salamander we're working to get in that
neck of the woods we're in talks with a
couple cons
uh in the general vicinity of El Paso
maybe we could try to get to El Paso
y'all still making salsa there
because some sauce is made in New York
City New York 30 year old referee
get what I'm talking about uh thank you
all so much uh for watching the show
today
um sorry let's get some fun stuff no uh
Jessica I apologize yeah please
no keep going no just because you got a
is your video up on the channel right
now yeah yeah it just came out before
this one uh she's gonna break down in
Witcher blood origin yeah
uh during our kind of Christmas vacation
but Jessica just a breakdown of the full
season check that out got some other
good videos coming out on the channel
soon
um including hey we're doing shorts we
got YouTube shorts on the channel not
just a fashion statement anymore guys
shorts are in that's right check those
out they're little things we're
experimenting with yeah
um get off Tick Tock it's ruining your
brains watch some shorts you don't need
out of context weird quotes from people
talking about doing gambling pics and
dancing all funny to songs what's on
here for you my my for you page is big
butts big boobs gambling tips casinos
foreign
chats uh come back tomorrow and Friday
we got two more wild fun shows in store
uh have a good rest of your day
everybody later skaters
[Music]